Today we discuss unconscionability through the classic case of Williams versus
Walker Thomas Furniture.
This case was decided in 1965 by a well known judge,
uh,
Jay Skelly,
right of the circuit court of the District of Columbia.
It also raises important questions about the respective roles of courts and
legislatures.
The facts orally.
Williams,
the defendant and appellant in this case purchased several items on installment
from the Walker Thomas Furniture Company.
The last of these items was a stereo set valued at over $500.
Ms. Williams,
a woman have limited education and means owed $164 from her prior purchases at
the time she bought the stereo.
The contracts for these goods contained in fine print,
a cross collateral clause.
In effect,
this clause gave the furniture company the right to repossess all of Mrs.
Williams prior purchases if she defaulted on the payments for one of her last
purchases,
even if you'd paid enough to previously pay off some of her dead on these
earlier purchases.
Ms. Williams did indeed default on a stereo payment and Walker Thomas Furniture
attempted to repossess all of her prior purchases.
So the procedural history was this,
the trial court found for Walker Thomas Furniture Company,
the district of Columbia Court of Appeals affirmed but the instant court with
Skelly right a reversed and remanded the case.
The central issue was this,
even though even the lower court that had ruled in favor of Walker Thomas
Furniture Company believed that the company's contracts were exploitive but
believe there was no basis not to enforce the contracts.
So the central issue is this,
can courts declined to enforce unconscionable contracts and were these contracts
unconscionable?
This central issue was a matter of first impression in the district of Columbia
in his opinion,
judge right look to provision of the uniform commercial code two dash three Oh
two,
uh,
which had just recently been enacted but had not yet taken effect and judge
right felt his power as a common law judge and relied on this provision even
though it wasn't enforced yet,
saying that was persuasive authority.
It was authority because he was persuaded by it.
And this provision says that courts can refuse to enforce contracts.
They find unconscionable judge right held that where the element of
unconscionability is present at the time a contract is made.
The contract should not be
the case was remanded in order to determine whether the contracts in questions
were in fact unconscionable.
Now in dissent,
Judge Donna her agreed with the lower court which found no basis for failing to
enforce the contract but concluded Congress you should consider corrective
legislation to protect the public from such exploitive contracts.
He emphasized the many public policy concerns,
the case involved and suggested that the court's decision might have unintended
negative effects on the on individuals of low income.
Maybe it would increase the interest at which they had to borrow money.
So let's make sure we understand the structure of the purchase at issue.
In this case,
first walker furniture sold goods on installment.
It's sales contract specified that instead of paying for an item all at once,
the purchaser would make regular smaller periodic rent payments on the items
purchased and the furniture company would retain title to it until the total
installment payments equal.
The item's value.
A transaction is structured in this way can be especially appealing for
individuals who want to give an item but don't have the ability to pay for it
all at once.
The very controversial provision in the Walker Thomas Furniture contracts was
the cross collateral clause.
This clause required that all installment payments on a given purchased to be
prorated against the amounts due on all purchases,
uh,
that uh,
a borrower such as Ms. Williams had outstanding.
This would keep open the debts on each purchase until all the goods were paid
for.
As a result,
the Walker Thomas Furniture Company retained a security interest in all of the
goods Ms. Williams bought until the balance on the last item she purchased with
paid.
This means that company could seize those goods to discharge a debt on whatever
item those good secured all of the goods that the Walker Thomas furniture
companies sold to Ms. Williams were security for the last thing she bought in
this case,
the stereo.
This meant that if Ms. Williams couldn't make the payment on that Stereo Walker
Thomas Furniture under this provision could take all of the goods that had
previously sold on credit to Ms. Williams.
This they did a Marshall seized from her,
among other things,
draperies and apron set,
a potholder set and rugs.
So now let's talk about unconscionability.
What does a unconscionability actually mean?
Well,
here's what the UCC section two three Oh two a says the provision that judge
right found pervasive.
If the court finds as a matter of law,
any clause of a contract to have been unconscionable at the time it was made,
the court may refuse to enforce the contract.
Comment one to that provision provide some additional guidance.
It says the basic test is whether in light of the general commercial background
and the commercial needs of the particular trade or case,
the clauses involved are so one sided as to be unconscionable under the
circumstances existing at the time of the making of the contract.
The principal is one of prevention of oppression and unfair surprise and not of
disturbance of allocation of risks because of superior bargaining power.
According to the UCC,
the primary factors and turn in determining unconscionability or whether it
causes depression and unfair surprise to one of the parties to a contract.
Judge Wright went into a considerably deeper discussion of unconscionability,
his meaning and his own opinion focusing on an absence of meaningful choice on
the part of one of the parties together with contractual terms which are
unreasonably favorable to the other party.
Acknowledging that both these factors are difficult to define.
Judge right nevertheless noted that meaningful choice could be negated by gross
inequality of bargaining power and by a party's lack of opportunity to
understand the terms of the contract.
Another common way of talking about unconscionability is to distinguish between
procedural unconscionability on one hand and substantive unconscionability on
the other.
The former refers to defects in the bargaining process,
the ladder to unfairness in the outcome of the process,
the terms of the agreed upon contract,
usually some mixture of both procedural and substantive unconscionability must
be present for a court to declare a CCO contract unconscionable.
The distinction between procedural and substantive unconscionability maps nicely
onto judge writes requirements of absence of meaningful choice and unreasonably
favorable terms respectively.
They also map onto the factors in UCC two dash three Oh two comment one the,
the issues of oppression and unfair surprise where there is procedural
unconscionability.
The victim is surprised to learn about the contract substantive,
uh,
unfairness.
Can you think of any instances in which either procedural or substantive
unconscionability on its own should be enough to avoid a contract?
Can you think of a contract that is substantively but not procedurally
unconscionable or vice versa?
Uh,
if you're,
uh,
knowledgeable of the Old Testament in the Bible,
you might think of two different contracts that Jacob entered into.
One which is dominantly,
uh,
unconscionable from a substantive standpoint.
And another is dominantly unconscionable.
From a procedural standpoint,
a party's level of education is relevant to whether there is procedural
unconscionability.
So was the way in which significant terms of the contract,
like the cross collateral clause at issue here are presented?
Uh,
the hiding of one sided terms in fine print is the paradigmatic example of
procedural unconscionability.
As for substantive unconscionability,
right.
Applied the test,
the Corbyn,
a famous commentator on contracts set forth whether the contracts terms are so
extreme as GOP are unconscionable according to the mores and business practices
of the time and place.
Richard Epstein is a famous libertarian law professor who tends to extol freedom
of contract with a libertarian like Epstein tend to have more concerns about
procedural or substantive unconscionability.
Well,
libertarians would tend to be more concerned about procedural unconscionability
if terms are hidden in fine print so that the non drafters surprised to learn
what she promised.
Then a libertarian might worry that the surprise party did not make a
sufficiently informed decision about whether or not to contract,
but Epstein famously saw that substantive Lee unconscionable terms could be
problematic because they're evidence of procedural unconscionability.
For example,
if the term is so unfavorable that no person in their right mind would have
agreed to it,
then the existence of substantively unconscionable terms in a contract is
evidence that there must have been some procedural defect in contracting.
Okay,
here's another quiz.
Did the DC circuit court find that Walker Thomas furnitures contract wasn't
unconscionable?
Yes or no?
Okay.
Well,
it's a trick question.
Judge Wright didn't actually decide this question.
He instead remanded the question for the lower court's consideration.
Ultimately the company settled with the plaintiff,
so no court made a final determination as to whether the cross collateral term
was unconscionable.
But lets us do that.
Considering the contract at issue against these various test,
what factors point toward or against unconscionability?
Well,
the way to approach this is to first break it down into procedural and
substantive,
uh,
questions.
There's pretty strong evidence of procedural unconscionability given the
convoluted language of the cross collateral term.
It's probable that the borrower,
a purchaser would not have understood that the seller was retaining a security
interest in all of the previous purchases.
But the harder question is whether the cross collateral clause is substantively
unconscionable.
This is much harder question because the law often allows borrowers to give
security,
uh,
that is higher in value than the amount that's being borrowed by over
securitizing the debt.
The borrower might receive more favorable terms,
including a lower interest rate.
Most home mortgages are over securitized because of the buyer's down payment.
Right now.
Uh,
my home mortgage is only about half as large as the amount of the value of the
House that,
uh,
that secures it.
It's also hard to see how the seller could earn an unconscionable windfall
profit from the over securitization as there's a duty to give any excess value
from seized assets back to the borrower.
Thus,
once security is seized,
the seller would have a duty to sell it at auction and any extra proceeds of the
auction after paying off the borrower's debt would be paid back to the borrower.
The cross collateral clause also seems substantively conscionable when we
consider that in the absence of any security interest,
a lender could seek a monetary judgment,
a court judgment against a defaulting borrower,
and normally would be able to hire a sheriff to seize any of the borrowers
assets.
And that means any of them in order to satisfy the monetary judgment.
So normally the lender would have been able to,
through the monetary judgment mechanism,
through getting a court order,
a court judgment to seize the same channel that were seized in this very case.
In fact,
Doug Baird discovered that one reason Walker Thomas might have used the cross
collateralization clause was to get around the effect of a very unusual local
code ordinance in the District of Columbia under this local statute.
All beds betting household furniture,
furnishings,
sewing machines,
radios,
stoves,
cooking utensils,
not exceeding $300 in value.
We're free and exempt from distrait attachment.
Levy seizure under any court order has Doug Baird explains Walker Thomas took
the security interest in Williams other household goods because these assets
where otherwise exempt from the monetary a judgment mechanism.
Baird says that Walker Thomas had to take a security interest in them in order
to be able to reach them.
In the event of a borrower default,
the cross collateralization clause,
uh,
Baird says,
serve this purpose and no,
no other purpose.
And possibly it was the Walker Thomas furnitures end run of the local code that
makes this term substantively unconscionable.
Finally,
let's consider the dissent in the case.
Why might someone in Ms. Williams position agree with the descent?
Well,
Judge Donna,
hers noted for instance,
that many poor people lack credit and thus pose a risk to companies selling
goods on installment.
Uh,
he suggested that companies might only be willing to sell goods on credit to
these individuals when they're pricing policies will afford the degree of
protection commensurate with the risk.
If courts refused to enforce Walker Thomas Furniture's contracts,
might the company,
uh,
see selling expensive items to low income purchasers at all or bite they charge
higher interest rate.
And who is that?
The court or the legislature in that is in the best position decide what
contractual terms are so exploited as to become unconscionable.
And so Walker Thomas Furniture also stands for our standard concern that
whenever the law imposes a mandatory restriction to protect,
uh,
buyers,
it,
the,
um,
perverse effect is that,
uh,
it might end up hurting them if the seller's react negatively enough to the
restriction.